Also, I invite you to join the discussion
on The David Pakman Show Subrata at nearly
30000. If you can imagine, nearly 30000
of our viewers and listeners are now
subscribed to The David Pakman Show sub Reddit.
You can find it at David Pakman dot com Reddit.
A few interesting posts I spotted this morning.
One asks, Why do you trumpet's need to believe
that Antifa was behind the January 6th
insurrection? Hear me out, says this user.
Let's imagine the insane world that the Trump is
live in is reality. The election was stolen from
Trump and there was rampant fraud in favor
of Joe Biden. It was rigged at every level
and Joe Biden is a illegitimate president. If
this is the case, then don't Trump supporters
have the moral obligation to take back their
country and reinstall Trump as president
since he was rightly elected? After all, the
Declaration of Independence says the people
have a right to alter or abolish an illegitimate
government. Going on to say my point is this
under the premise that the
election was truly stolen,
then they shouldn't need to blame Antifa for the
riots, since the people at the capital should have
gone even farther in their actions to prevent
Biden from becoming president. In other words,
none of the Trump is Republicans should be
condemning the insurrectionists or blaming
antifa. They should be embracing their actions
of the actions of the insurrectionists instead.
This is a very important point, and this is
something that we've been talking about for
a long time, which is very often these radical
conspiratorial hypotheses from the right conflict.
And this is this is the epitome of that. On the
one hand, you have people who for two months
following the lead of Trump and Rudy Giuliani and
all these other people believed the election was
really stolen. Joe Biden didn't really win. Donald
Trump actually won. If that actually is true,
then, of course, they would go to the capital on
January 6th. And again, they went because they
did believe that that was true. So then why would
they be blaming Antifa? They really would be there
as people demanding that the rightful winner of
the presidential election be installed. It would
be Trump that would go. You wouldn't need to point
the finger at Antifa. Are we meant to believe now
that they really believe the election was stolen
and they were willing to do whatever it took?
Just like Donald Trump said, you've got to
fight for it, just like Rudy said, trial by
combat or whatever it was. But then they didn't
actually go on January six. They stayed home
even though they were ready and willing
to fight for their president. Now,
it's incoherent and this is very accurately
pointing it out. Another interesting post from
the subhead. It argues that good Republicans
don't exist. This user says there is no rot
within the Republican Party. The Republican
Party is the rot right down to its moldy core.
Everything Republicans stand for is wrong
politically. They stand for tax cuts for the rich
D unionization, sucking off the military
industrial complex, trickle down economics
and brown people are bad ideologically. They
stand for LGBTQ is bad. Women's rights is bad,
more votes bad, brown people bad again. Living
wages are socialism, affordable health care,
socialism, fighting climate change is socialism
on and on. And they go on to say, tell me honestly
what actual honest to back Christ good
comes from the continued existence of the
Republican Party. What's a single genuinely
good thing they do for the American people
and not just the one percent, the wealthiest one
percent of their base? And to a great degree,
this is true. And what I mean by that is there
are people who I disagree with politically,
but who I don't think are out of their mind,
bad people necessarily in the Republican Party,
moderate Republicans whose priorities are they
are socially I don't want to say socially liberal,
but socially libertarian, let's say, and
really genuinely believe that, you know,
regulations, not socialism, but that
the country is better off with less
regulation and lower taxes and whatever. OK, I
mean, these these are political disagreements
as old as as old as government itself. But to
a great degree, this is accurate, where you
have essentially the worst instincts of just bad
people coalesced around. Really horrible leaders,
Donald Trump being the sort of greatest example
of that, and they make a lot of good points,
as I think the point I would make. Join the
discussion at David Pakman dot com slash Reddit